Good afternoon.
Can everyone hear me fine?
Welcome to Aerocene and the
Future in a Fossil-Free World.
I'm thrilled to be moderating
and making introductions,
guiding the conversation
this evening
with an extraordinary
group of people.
And we are welcoming Tomás
Saraceno here at MIT.
The event is co-sponsored by
the MIT Center for Art, Science
& Technology and the MIT
Department of Architecture.
My name is John Fernández.
I'm a professor
in the Department
of Architecture in the
Building Technology Program.
And I'm the director of
the Environmental Solutions
Initiative, MIT'S
institute-wide effort
to mobilize the capacity
of our researchers,
our students, our community
to offer solutions
on climate change and other
environmental challenges
that we face in this century.
It's a wonderful group.
It's a highly
distinguished group.
It's a very
multidisciplinary group.
And because they are
so distinguished,
I have long
introductions for you.
So bear with me.
It's worth going through them.
And I will go through
them in detail
because I do think that this is
the best way to set up what has
really motivated this event.
And that is to bring
disciplines together
that are quite disparate and
often distant from one another
on our greatest
societal challenges
as one of the pathways towards
solving those challenges,
really addressing
those challenges.
So beginning with Tomás
Saraceno right here, Tomás,
his work could be seen as
ongoing research informed
by worlds of art, architecture,
natural sciences, astrophysics,
and engineering and material
science, and other things,
actually.
His floating sculptures and
interactive installations
propose and explore new
sustainable ways of inhabiting
and sensing the environment.
Aerocene, an open-source
community project
for artistic and
scientific exploration
initiated from
Saraceno's vision,
becomes buoyant only
by the heat of the sun
and infrared radiation from
the surface of the Earth.
In 2015, Saraceno
achieved the world record
for the first and longest
certified fully solar man
flight.
During the past decade, he
has initiated collaborations
with renowned
scientific institutions,
including MIT, the
Max Planck Institute,
the Nanyang Technological
University of Singapore,
and the Natural History
Museum in London.
He was the first person
to scan, reconstruct,
and reimagine spiders' woven
spatial habitats and possesses
the only three-dimensional
spider web collection
in existence.
I gather you were chasing
spiders this afternoon.
Saraceno lectures in
institutions worldwide
and directed the Institute
of Architecture-related Art
at Braunschweig University
of Technology in Germany
and has held residencies
at Centre National d'Etudes
Spatiales, MIT's Center for
Art, Science & Technology,
and the Atelier
Calder, among others.
I'm going to go through
all the introductions.
OK.
And then the sequence will
be that they will be giving
10-minute--
10-minute-- presentations.
And then we'll have
a panel discussion.
Joining us is Lodovica
Illari and, really,
the host for Tomás today, is
a senior lecturer in the MIT
Department of Earth, Atmospheric
and Planetary Sciences.
She earned a PhD in
atmospheric sciences
at Imperial College
London in 1982.
She teaches large-scale dynamics
and synoptic meteorology
in MIT'S undergraduate
and graduate programs.
She's responsible for
the Synoptic Laboratory.
Illari's research interests
are in synoptic meteorology,
severe weather, and
atmospheric blocking.
She's also involved in
developing innovative teaching
methods that combine fluid
laboratories with synoptic data
and outreach to the
public and schools,
therefore the
connection to Aerocene.
Recently, she has collaborated
with MIT visiting artist Tomás
Saraceno on the Aerocene project
imagining how solar infrared
balloons can be used to teach
about Earth climate and sample
atmospheric constituents.
We also have--
thrilled to have Dan.
Welcome, Dan Cziczo, also
from the MIT Department
of Earth, Atmospheric
and Planetary Sciences.
He's professor of atmospheric
chemistry since 2011.
And his research
focuses on the role
that particulate matter plays
in atmospheric chemistry,
visibility, and
cloud formations.
Visiting his lab is
quite an experience.
He creates very small
atmospheres in his machines,
actually.
Examples include understanding
how aerosols nucleate water
and ice clouds, improving
the quantification
of meteoritic ablation products
and determining the abundance
of aircraft and rocket exhaust.
Cziczo's undergraduate work
was in aerospace engineering.
And he spent two years at
the Jet Propulsion Laboratory
performing spacecraft
navigation before starting
his graduate work.
Cziczo received an MS and
PhD in geophysical sciences
from the University of Chicago
for work with Professor John
Abbott.
His postdoctoral fellowship
was with Dr. Daniel Murphy
at NOAA [INAUDIBLE] Laboratory,
and he spent three years
at the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology
working with Professor
Ulrike Lohmann.
Before coming to MIT, Cziczo
was a research scientist
at the Pacific Northwest
National Laboratory,
where he directed their
atmospheric measurement
laboratory.
And finally, Bob Jaffe is
the Jane and Otto Morningstar
professor of physics at MIT.
A theoretical
physicist, his research
focuses on the physics
of elementary particles
and quantum field theory,
especially the dynamics
of quark confinement
and the standard model.
He has served as an advisor to
several national laboratories
and universities, including
as chair of the Science
and Engineering Steering
Committee of the Brookhaven
National Laboratory.
At MIT, Jaffe has
served as chair
of the faculty and
director of the Center
for Theoretical Physics
and has received
many awards for teaching
and course development.
From 2008 to 2016,
Jaffe was a member
of the American
Physical Society's panel
on public affairs, which
he chaired in 2015.
In 2011, Jaffe led a joint
American Physical Society panel
on public affairs and MRS study
on energy-critical elements
securing materials for
emerging technologies.
And together with Professor
Washington Taylor,
Jaffe developed and
taught a new course
on the physics of
energy, which was
adopted as a foundational
requirement for MIT'S energy
minor degree.
The textbook, which we all
waited with bated breath
to come out and has been
out since March, correct?
Mm-hmm.
--is an outgrowth of the
course, the Physics of Energy,
and was published
this past March.
Jaffe is a fellow of the
American Academy of Arts
and Sciences, the
American Association
for the Advancement of Science,
and the American Physical
Society.
So welcome to all.
I'd like to have Tomás come up
and give us your presentation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, hello?
Hello?
Yes.
Can you hear me?
Yes, wonderful.
Maybe we can turn a
little bit down the light
if it's possible.
[INAUDIBLE]
Sorry?
Video.
LLB.
50%.
Thank you.
I'm a visual artist
sometimes, and I love it.
We try to focus on the images.
And the other thing is
that I promised today
that I would really try to
keep it within 10 minutes.
And maybe you kind of
held me to the nine.
Oh, you got it.
What should I say?
It is a honor.
And I'm very, very happy
to be back at my team.
I feel a little bit
being at home sometimes.
And they say, oh,
when we come today.
I'm again with good friends.
And this means I'm very,
very happy to be here back.
And there are things
a little bit--
what is happening
with the project is,
somehow, it became so
much weather dependent.
So we have been so much
talking during the last days
that it's cloudy.
And hopefully the
sun will come out
to be able to perform
some activities.
Down the road, there is
engagement psychologically
that somehow I became much
more aware of the weather
down the road.
Now, I have a presentation.
I will really try to compress
it and go as fast as possible
and try to match
it into 10 minutes.
There we go.
This is one of my
favorite places on Earth,
the Salar de Uyuni in Bolivia.
When it's covered with
a thin layer of water,
the clouds reflect.
And there are days
one feels as if you
were floating in the clouds.
But there are days when
the horizon disappears.
And there is never
either above nor below.
You feel immersed
in something bigger.
Where does the sky end
and the Earth begin?
And it was there that one
night, in the middle of a dream,
I woke up.
And I saw that the stars
also reflected on the water.
And it was not a dream.
It was like I could
walk among the stars.
Every step I took, the stars
reverberated under my feet.
And it was like feeling
floating in the universe
among the clouds of galaxies.
I do not know about
you, but I always
dream about floating
among the clouds.
And today, maybe we can
imagine this together.
We can live in an ecosystem
floating among the clouds.
Cloud cities is a
long-term project of mine
where we speculate and venture
of new urban dwellings,
nomadic and transnational.
They belong to everybody.
It does not depend on any
type of [INAUDIBLE] in the way
that we hope that cloud
cities could anticipate
a borderless, open-source,
free-flying utopian existence.
And as we said
before, imagine is
the force that can lead
us to create new places.
This is an installation I did
on a roof of the Metropolitan
Museum in New York
in which we speculate
how this transnational
space could be.
The image of the
Earth from space
does not show any borders,
any special constraint.
But on it, we build vertical
and horizontal boundaries.
This image, for example,
shows that airspace
is divided into
sections, allowing
different topology of
fossil fuel aircraft
to each one of them and
project national borders
into the atmosphere.
It causes a nightmare
every time we
launch one of these sculptures
to cross their airspace.
This is why I think
we could not let
it fly from here because there
are too many airports nearby.
While enterprises to colonize
other planets are put in place,
this very same
interface between us
and the sun and the atmosphere
continues to be compromised.
Carbon emissions fill the air.
Invisible radio waves develop
in a hegemonic algorithm
of dominance.
Particulate matter
floats inside our lungs.
Air has been colonized
by drones, satellites,
and military devices
and strictly regulated
by national policies and land.
How could breathing feel in
a post-fossil fuel economy?
It is urgent to rethink
how we can coexist
with a planet and its
resources and what
a stratigraphy of the
future will look like.
Yet, what would float
today in the water
are not only cloud of galaxies
but also cloud of plastics.
These are the traces that we
are leaving on the planet,
are the marks of
the era in which
the behavior of some people
is leaving a global impact
on the rest of the ecosystem.
This time has been
named the Anthropocene.
All of these have
transformed the way
human senses react to the air.
To achieve long-lasting
change, people
must relearn the relationship
with the elements
and understand, how can we
live in tandem with them
rather than control it?
To be aware of the air is to
sense it to one's environment.
To be aware of the element which
sustain you, transmit, carry.
If you leave a room, vacate
a building, climb a mountain,
float in the sea, you are
still contained within the air.
The air senses the environment.
But there is also any kind
of social structure thing.
So we kind of run late.
We got five minutes.
A little bit to understand
the beginning of the project,
we start to collect a
lot of plastic bags.
We wash them.
We take care.
We cut them.
We paste them.
And we begin to draw on them.
Creating gigantic
canvases, we create
a collection of growing personal
stories and friendships.
[CHEER]
And when the canvas unite
fold bends, a space is formed.
Once full of air, it's
not a matter of time
until the air inside the
sculpture in the sun coming up
from the horizon, the sculpture
rises up into the air.
As simple as it looks.
The way how it floats is
really, really simple.
As such, that is
so simple, there
is also no plant or animal
who floats in the same way
how this sculpture floats.
There's no plant or animal
in the entire planet
who floats by this
differential of temperature.
There are many pollen, bacterias
who are raised in the thermics.
And they might get
up into the air
but not by these
differential of temperature.
It's the same as a cumulus.
When you float in the water,
you put your lungs full of air.
And then somehow, you float
in the water in the same way
these sculptures
get up into the air.
And in this way, we
don't use fossil fuel
like a normal balloon might
have a burner or a candle.
And then many other
people are also
heating the air through
solar panel batteries
and then using also,
many times, helium,
which is a byproduct many times
of fossil fuel instructions.
And hydrogen is quite
complicated, also, to make it.
Following on that, we
thought, oh, maybe we
could think about
a new epoch who
might get us more
proactive in that extent
and think about different
metabolic regime of how humans
also have inhabited the Earth.
And this might be the
fourth metabolic regime,
to a certain extent.
And this is why these
is the backpack.
And these are the backpacks.
There is this sculpture.
And this is the one that
we will try tomorrow
on Friday and on Saturday
to get up into the air.
They have different
devices, which
I think is what, with
Lodo and many communities
around the world, we are
trying to optimize and to think
of how we could sense
the air differently.
In this case, there's
a motion tracker.
And then make these
beautiful drawings.
There are different
communities around the world
which are really hacking,
transforming, and changing.
This means I'm
very happy to hear
what will be the devices
we will lift up tomorrow.
Here, there's a
performance that we
are trying to put up together.
There is Joaquin, which is
coming from Argentina, also.
And he's working
with a community.
You want to tell
us two words only?
Two words?
Yes.
Very fast.
Yeah.
Hi there.
My pleasure.
I'm just going to show
you brief images of how
we're building a community
around the Aerocene project
in Argentina.
This is how we brainstorm.
We get together for [INAUDIBLE]
and we discussed-- or barbecue.
We discussed some ideas with
Tomás and a group of people
in Buenos Aires
back in December.
And I'd like to just tell
you about this woman, who's
called Debora, and wrote
a book called Flammable
about this community living
near a petrochemical plant.
And basically, it's very
near the center of the city.
And they have huge
health problems.
And so we have
partnered with people
to create an air
quality monitor.
And we have been
talking with MIT people
today to see how we can improve
this and basically get the air
quality monitor airborne.
And also, we are thinking about
ideas of having an aerial mesh
network that is 100% solar
powered, the first ever
solar-powered
aerial mesh network.
And over to Tomás.
Yes, I think we have one minute.
Or zero.
I can stop whenever you want.
I don't have any pressure.
But yeah, there is a lot
of life up into the air.
While some of the
sculptures, yes, they
have been free flying, we
launched some from Berlin
most of the time.
We get a lot of problem with
getting the air regulation
being able to tune with
these type of sculptures.
We will be next week talking
with a European minister
of transportation trying
to change the rite of pass
for these type of vehicles.
This means also we
are trying to set up
a different legal
framework in relation
with insurance and
translation of papers.
And we will try to lift up also
the minister up into the air.
This means some of
the things that we
have been doing with
Lodo, and I think
she will show the floating
predictor, and Glenn
and Bill and EAPS.
It's this idea of really
being able to circumnavigate
the Earth also during
the night and picking up
the infraradiation from
the air, something which
CNES, the French
Space Agency, have
been doing during the '70s.
And somehow, the program
had been forgotten.
Yeah, OK.
These are some of the
sculptures that we present
you COP21 conference in Paris
at the Grand Palais, which
are the ones that
more or less will
be able to fly also during
the night and ride the wind.
So a lot of these,
you will talk about.
This means I skip that slide.
But what we want is
kind of artistic, also.
It's like all these drawings,
feather flight, free fly,
or imaginary flights.
This collection,
somehow, it will
become kind of a signature
towards maybe an Independence
Day of fossil fuel that
we are all trying to sign.
We were collecting
all these drawings,
and we are lifting up different
people up into the air, also.
And this was a performance which
was done in the White Sands
in New Mexico, where it
was kind of the beginning
of the Anthropocene
with the first atomic--
stop.
OK, I stop.
I promised 10 minutes.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
We did the connection.
Could I?
Hi.
It's a great pleasure to be
here and also a big task to me
to follow Tomás's step.
But what I'm going to do is
talk a bit about the science
we did in the Aerocene project.
And the work I'm going to
describe is not only my work.
It's in very close collaboration
with Professor Glenn Flierl
and Bill McKenna, both in EAPS.
And the collaboration with Tomás
started quite a few years ago.
And I'm mainly focusing
on describing some work
on exploring the
use of solar balloon
as a platform for
observing the atmosphere.
Tomás has already
mentioned that in his talk.
On the side here--
sorry, I want to go back.
But you are just
seeing the movie of one
of these solar balloons.
And this is the one we try
to fly again this weekend.
And that describes a little bit
more what we want to do next.
So the stages of
our collaboration,
I split it in three--
some study of historical
balloons from the French Space
Agency that we presented
in Paris at COP21.
Then some work on virtual
balloon flights with the float
predictor that Tomás
had just mentioned.
And then some tethered
balloon, the explorer
that we want to use for chemical
sampling of the atmosphere
and particles on campus.
So this is the French
attempt, a very successful use
of solar balloons.
They're actually called
Montgolfiere Infrarouge.
They're solar and infrared.
And this is one of the balloons.
It's a huge one.
It's intended to reach
the stratosphere.
And it's filled with just air.
And it's got a
particular configuration.
If you look in here
at the diagram,
you can see the top is a
polyester cover with aluminum.
So if the sun shines on it,
the aluminum gets very hot,
heats the air
inside the balloon.
And it gets expanded.
The air expands.
It becomes buoyant.
But there is a
particular feature
that I want to point out
on the bottom of the-- it's
transparent.
If you notice here, it's
actually transparent.
And it's deliberately
done because he
wants to harness also the
infrared radiation from hertz.
So you know that the Earth
is a body which emits
in all directions infrared.
And so some of these
infrared radiation
would be captured
by the balloon.
So imagine the sun goes down.
The air inside gets colder.
But enough infrared radiation
is captured to keep it buoyant.
And this is the name,
Montgolfiere Infrarouge.
And here is data that we
acquired through the airport
Tomás--
from his internship
at CNES, real data
of one of these flights launched
in Brazil in February, 2004.
It reached 25 kilometers
high in the stratosphere.
And it then got colder because
the night came, came down,
then up again, and then down
again the following night.
And then it adjusted to a kind
of fluctuating day and night
undulation from between
25 and 20 kilometers.
And it flew like
that for 12 days.
This is a 12-days track,
very smoothly steady on wind
from east to west.
And just to describe
the structure
of the wind in the atmosphere,
we made a section here.
And the blue and cyan, we have
wind blowing from the west.
And in the pink
and gold, we have
wind blowing from the east.
So clearly, at this
level in the stratosphere
at this particular latitude,
you have a very strong flow
from the east.
And this is what was used
to make the balloon travel.
The idea, the balloon was
intended to measure chemicals--
ozone, methane, water
vapor, all chemicals
very sensitive to
the climate of Earth.
And I just want to mention
that many flights were
done by the CNES.
And there's a record of 72 days.
So they kept it up for 72
days is the record in 2001.
And it was very
successful in the tropics.
They had more
problem in the Arctic
because you can imagine that if
you have clouds at low level,
then they stop the
infrared radiation.
And the balloon will come up.
So very successful for
the tropical exploration
of the stratosphere, but not
so much for the extratropic
in the Arctic.
So Saraceno, after
his internship,
came to visit Azir at MIT.
He wanted to repropose
this technology.
And we made a study of the data.
And we presented
the work at COP21.
And I think this was the
beginning of our collaboration.
And I actually was
hooked on this data.
It was amazing
for me to discover
that you could keep a
balloon of that dimension
for so long flying
in the stratosphere.
Now, the second part
of our collaboration
is instead involving
and saying, well,
this Aerocene sculpture go--
I want to mention here Tomás
doesn't call them balloons
anymore because
they're beautiful.
They're really much
better than the other one
I've just shown you.
These are his sculptures
presented at COP21 in Paris.
And so the question
that he has is where
these sculptures could go.
Can I go up on one level,
come down on the other,
take the westerly, the
easterly, go around in a circle?
And so we developed together
with Professor Glenn Flierl
and Bill an
interactive interface
to be able to check where
this virtual balloon could go.
So I want to give you a
quick demonstration of this.
And I'm going out now.
I'm going to be
kind of adventurous,
going out on the web.
And this is something that
is going to be available
for you to explore
after the talk
and also tomorrow in Lobby 10.
And it's plotted here.
It's an interactive interface.
We can actually move
the sphere and check.
This is the wind at
10 kilometers high.
The wind speed coded in
color from weak to strong
is the pink is very strong.
And you see the
traditional, common feature
of jet in the atmosphere.
We are all familiar with the
jet stream covering the weather
system.
And this is actually
driven by today's data.
This is the forecast
data that is
used for the 10-day forecast.
It's actually 16-day forecast
from the National Weather
Service.
So I want to give you
just a small example
of what you could do.
So imagine I'm saying
I start from Boston,
and I'm now at 10 kilometers
high with this wind.
Where should I go?
So I click here.
And immediately, you have
an interactive trajectory
computing following the flow.
So this, you're following.
So the flow is evolving.
And you're moving with the
flow, like the balloon of Tomás.
And you can see that it reached
Europe and the Mediterranean.
It's got diverted quite a bit.
And then it's come
back in the jet.
But it's not managed
to go around the globe.
Now, the wind is very
different at different level.
If you scroll through, you
can see the difference.
Much weaker at the surface,
stronger at the jet level,
then strong again
but weaker at Europe.
And I'm choosing
the 25 kilometer
because it's where the
Montgolfiere Infrarouge used
to fly.
And now I'm trying to do the
same experiment that they
were used to do with this wind.
I'm put in a balloon here
and see where it will go.
And you can see they were
pretty clever, the French.
They knew there was this
band of easterly flow.
And they could follow.
And if I show you the
change of this trajectory,
I think it is going to go around
all the globe in approximately
15 days.
And exploring this interface
has been good not only
for exploring the wind
and the atmosphere
but also teaching the main
feature of the atmosphere
in my classes.
So it's been a great
development from the point
of view of our teaching.
So I'm going to go back
to the presentation
and show you the
third stage, which
is making use instead not free
flight, but a tethered balloon.
You can imagine that
you have a free flight.
You have to go through
permission from the FAA.
It's not easy.
And so we thought, why not try
to experiment with a smaller
balloon which has tether
and try to use them
to sample pollution in
the lower troposphere?
So this is our first
attempt last summer in July,
when it was very hot.
It went up.
It got buoyant very easily.
It got up.
It got up nearly at the
top of the Green Building.
We have to keep it down because
we couldn't raise it higher
than the Green Building.
And then we did another
experiment in October.
And tomorrow and next Saturday
will be our third attempt
with different sensor.
So the science
application is monitoring
atmospheric chemical
and particles
in the lower troposphere.
The collaboration this time
is with Professor Jesse Kroll
and his student, which is
an expert in monitoring.
But he mainly does
it at the ground.
He's not done really
vertical profile.
So he's really excited to try
to test the vertical profile
of this pollutant.
Which variable are we
interested in monitoring?
What can we measure, and where?
Here, we try to
summarize a little bit
that there are different
variables because there
are different structures.
If you look at NOX,
which is a big pollutant,
it's really confined in
the lower troposphere.
This is also zone product of
interaction with NOX, which is
also very local in the lower.
Carbon monoxide is also local
down in the troposphere.
And then a lot of
different particles,
they could be residual
from combustion.
They could be dust.
And they can spread as high
as 10 kilometers, even more.
And Dan will talk about those.
He's an expert.
Ozone tends to be
concentrated higher up.
And this is where those
stratospheric flights,
we are trying to measure.
The maximum ozone production is
actually around 20 kilometers.
And the usual thermodynamic
variable that I'm interested in
is in meteorology.
It's temperature.
Humidity will also be a target.
How can we measure them?
So we want to create
a community of users
all over the world to
measure this quantity
and with the balloons.
But what type?
We can use the mere balloon
higher up, a suggestion to you.
Imagine it hovering up and down
for 72 days or even longer,
if you can, and taking
measurements of ozone, methane.
Very important for
the greenhouse effect.
And lower here, much easier.
And we can even do it
on campus with students
and measure the pollution
with this tethered balloon.
So we're going to try to do this
tomorrow if the sun comes out.
If it doesn't tomorrow,
forecast is telling us--
not mostly.
I wrote this
presentation yesterday.
It's actually sunny
without the "mostly" now.
So I'm very confident
Saturday will be a good day.
So take your time.
Come out.
And come to watch us.
Now, finally and just the last
thing is this is an [INAUDIBLE]
for an educational activity,
I think educational,
which is ongoing, which we
call it EsGlobe, Environmental
science Globe.
It's a project
funded by the ASI.
And the idea is to
have an interactive way
of displaying data, very
similar to what I've shown you
for the Aerocene.
But you can be any data.
And you can manipulate it, plot
it in the sphere, and use it.
So I just finish and
say come to join us
and explore this
in the lobby here.
I'm with Tomás at Davos.
And a lot of the visitors,
participants sometimes
were very intrigued
and try to guess where
they could fly in the world.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So I wanted to start out by
saying thank you to Lodo.
It was a real pleasure
getting the invitation
to come and speak
to you all tonight.
Growing up, one of
my heroes in science
was Richard Feynman, who
is a fantastic physicist
but was always very
passionate about talking
about how he spent time with
artists, because there were
these two different
parts of your brain
that needed to be exercised.
And so he would sort of talk
physics with these folks
and listen to their
work and art and felt
that it made him a better
scientist as a result.
And I've really felt
that way about talking
about this project and
dealing with this project
and was very, very
interested to participate.
So one of the things that we
were asked to do this evening
was tell you a little
bit about our research
and how it was related
to the Aerocene project.
And so I work in the
area of climate change,
as John mentioned to start out.
And so I'm not only a scientist,
but I'm also an avid historian.
And so I love the history
behind the science that we do.
And so I'm starting out here
with one of my favorite quotes,
which is by George Santayana.
"Those who cannot remember the
past are condemned to repeat
it."
And I think that this is
especially true of climate.
And so what I
thought I'd start out
by doing tonight is telling you
a little bit about the climate
of our planet, the work that
we're doing in it, and then
get back to how
I think we can do
it better with the type of
technology which also happens
to be the art that you're
hearing about this weekend.
So this is the
temperature history
of the Earth in the past.
And this goes back almost
a million years in time.
And one of the things
that you can see about it
is that the Earth has been
warmer for periods of time,
and it's been colder
for periods of time.
And over the course of this
time, you can see that in blue
here, these are ice ages when
the Earth has been much colder.
There's also these
peaks in temperature
when the Earth has been warmer.
We should actually
be rather thankful
that currently
we're living in what
we call an interstitial period.
And the average temperature
of our planet right
now is about 57
degrees, which if we
had the average temperature
in Boston the last few weeks,
I think we'd all be quite happy.
But over the course of
the year, over the whole
of the planet that you just
saw in those beautiful images,
it works out that we're
at about 57 degrees.
And so one of the
things that you
can ask about,
because we're talking
about this idea of an
Anthropocene, the time period
that we as humans
have affected--
but the climate of our planet
really changes quite a bit
over time.
And you can wonder, how
much of this is natural?
And it turns out that over
history, over almost 100 years
ago now, people had worked
out that the temperature
of our planet is very
variable, that you
have to go through
these ice ages
and these interstitial periods.
And it has nothing to do
with us as humans being
on the surface of the planet.
Of course, we weren't there for
most of the time in that figure
that I just showed you.
And a very, very smart scientist
by the name of Milankovitch
figured this out and
realized that this
had to do with the orbital
mechanics of our planet, how
our planet is
tilting on its axis
when it's slightly further or
slightly closer to the sun.
But if you zoom in on
that temperature record,
you start to realize that
the temperature of our planet
has changed a great deal over
just the last few generations.
And this is highlighted
in blue on the figure
that you can see here.
So instead of these big
swings in temperature
that took tens of
thousands of years,
over just the last
100 years or so,
the planet has gotten
a great deal warmer.
The blue, actually, on here
is the instrumental record.
It's the period
of time for which
we've had accurate thermometers
to make measurements
of climate.
And that should
give us some sense
of how recently we've
only begun to understand
the planet that we live on.
It's only just over
about 100 years
that we've been able to tell
about the climate of our planet
and really understand it.
By the way, that longest
record of temperature
that we have for
the United States
was actually made
just south of us.
It was made in the Blue Hills
starting in about the 1880s.
What you'll realize as opposed
to looking at the last plot
that I showed you, where
temperatures swung wildly
over these tens of
thousands of years,
this is about the
length of human history.
Human history goes
back, of course,
a few thousand years further
than this recorded history.
But this is going back into
the ages of the Roman Empire.
And what you'll notice
instead of these wild swings
of many degrees of
temperature, instead,
everything on this plot is
within about a half a degree.
So that 57 degrees that I
said for the global average
hasn't changed more than
about a half a degree
in that period of time.
And so one of the
points that we have
to understand when
we start talking
about the Anthropocene,
the effect
that we've had on
the planet around us,
is that we've grown as
a civilization in a very
stable climate, perhaps
the most stable climate
that this planet has seen
in over a million years.
And so this is no coincidence
that this has happened.
We've really benefited
from this and this ability
to evolve in a world
that's very stable.
But we're starting to
move outside of that.
And so I mentioned that
I was a history buff.
And so one of my
personal interests
is understanding
how it is that we've
been able to understand
how we're affecting
the climate of our planet.
And so this is one of
my favorite scientists.
This is John Tyndall,
who is a Brit.
And he was very interested in
building different instruments
just like we do in
our lab, the one
that John mentioned
a few moments ago,
to understand how the
temperature of the planet
is what it is.
And so this is
something that he called
a comparative spectrometer.
And he was able to fill this
tube with different gases
and try to understand how they
interacted with solar radiation
and infrared radiation, those
two things that are powering
the Aerocene balloons that
you're going to be seeing more
about in the next few days.
And so what Tyndall realized
was that most of our atmosphere,
most of what we breathe,
is nitrogen and oxygen.
And it has no effect on the
temperature of our planet.
But there's a few key
elements out there,
carbon dioxide being
one of them, which
is a so-called greenhouse gas.
It absorbs that infrared
energy, the same thing
that powers these
balloons, this MRI that you
were hearing about at night.
And it allows that
energy to be trapped,
much like a blanket
around the planet.
And it raises the temperature
of the planet as a result.
Now, mind you, from the dates
that you're seeing on there,
Tyndall was doing his work
in the mid to late 1800s.
And he had already
really figured out
the basics of the climate
of our planet at that time.
So if you ever hear that
climate change is something
that we're just
figuring out right now,
I'll talk about that
in a few moments.
But really, the basics
of this were all
worked out in the mid 1800s.
And Tyndall's famous for
writing a paper about how
if we didn't have these
wonderful greenhouse
gases around our planet, we'd
be caught in an icy grip.
And so that takes
us to the next part
of our story, who
is a scientist that
followed on Tyndall's work.
This was Svante
Arrhenius, and he
was working at the
end of the 1800s
and the beginning of the 1900s.
And he was really
intrigued by this idea
that there were these materials
in our atmosphere that
could make it warmer or colder.
And so what Arrhenius
did was figure
out how much warmer
the planet would
be as a result of
having different amounts
of these greenhouse gases.
And so he looked at
doubling the amount of CO2,
for example, and seeing how much
warmer the planet would get.
And he wasn't
interested in doing
this for altruistic purposes.
You might think
that he was worried
about greenhouse gases and
global warming, the things
that we're talking about,
for example, at the COP21
conference.
Arrhenius was actually
from Scandinavia,
and he was interested in trying
to make the planet warmer.
The winters were too long
for him, much like us
in Boston this year.
And so he was very
interested in doing things
like lighting coal on fire
to try to make the planet
warmer as a result. So not
quite thinking about things
the same way we do now.
So what have we done?
What is this Anthropocene
that we've been talking about?
Well, largely, it's this input,
this burning of fossil fuels
and the input of carbon dioxide
and other greenhouse gases
to our atmosphere.
And one of the results
that this has had
is to warm the
temperature of the planet.
So we're now warmer
than we probably
have been in the last
several thousand years
at least, perhaps many
tens of thousands of years.
And so over that instrumental
record that I just told you
about, the warmest years
on record from 1 to 20
are on the upper right here.
I haven't updated this recently.
2017 just came in about a month
ago at number two on this plot.
And so I often think about this
because when we tell people
that the climate that
children will grow up in
is different than the
climate that we grew up in,
the climate that
we're experiencing now
is already different than it
was when we were growing up.
None of the first
years of my life
are actually on the top
20 years on this plot.
They all fall below that.
The climate of the
last few decades
has been radically different.
This Anthropocene has led to
a radically different world
already now that we're
living in than we experienced
even a generation ago.
So one of the things that
we do a great deal of
is trying to understand exactly
what the climate of our planet
is.
And unfortunately, even
thanks to the work of Tyndall
and Arrhenius back at the
late 1800s, early 1900s,
they missed a few things
in their calculations.
They weren't able to get
the climate of the planet
quite right.
And one of the reasons is that--
this is actually a beautiful
image of the planet, something
that I had on my wall as a child
from the Japanese Space Agency.
But I think we already know, and
Tomás showed an earlier picture
of this.
What is this missing?
Clouds.
The planet at any one
time should actually
look like this, not
the other picture.
And until we understand
the particulate matter
in our atmosphere, we can't
understand the climate.
So particles scatter some of
that incoming solar radiation,
just like the greenhouse
gases are trapping
some of those outgoing
terrestrial radiation,
the infrared radiation that
was spoken about before.
Beyond that, we've even changed
the properties of the clouds
in our atmosphere.
There's more clouds now
than there were earlier
before this Anthropocene onset.
And so understanding
all of these things
is something that we
critically need to do.
So with my last few
seconds, what I want to do
is try to bring this back full
circle to one of the reasons
that I'm so excited
about this project, which
is making these measurements
in our atmosphere
is extremely costly.
You can think about having to
go out and do research or get
a research aircraft and fly
it at the cost of many tens
of thousands of dollars.
The idea of having these
incredible small platforms,
things that can be sort of
crowdsourced to do measurements
on a very local scale
but maybe in many places
at the same time, can
really add to the knowledge
that we currently
have about our planet,
really help us reduce
that uncertainty
in how climate is going to
be changing into the future.
So with that, I'll
say thank you.
I really appreciate
the chance to come out.
And I'm looking forward
to the panel after this.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
Well, thank you to
Lodo and the rest
of the organizers for the
opportunity to talk here.
I first met Tomás, it must be
over five years ago when he was
artist in residence here.
And I was fascinated
immediately by the imagination
and creativity of his sculptures
and also by his dedication
to the problems faced by the
culture and by our environment.
I did struggle to figure out
exactly what I was invited
to talk about since I don't
work on either the Aerocene
or directly on the atmosphere.
But I have spent
the past 10 years
studying, teaching,
and now writing
about the uses, sources, and
systems that involve energy.
So I thought I would
take some of the lessons
from what I've
learned and taught
and just provide
some basic picture
about a couple of
issues that follow
from the physics of energy.
The two topics I'm
going to talk about,
and I'm going to be very brief
and very not technical, I hope,
are the scale of
the problem we face
in trying to convert our culture
to sustainable energy sources
and, secondly, a
couple of lessons
from the second law
of thermodynamics.
So first, let me
talk about scale.
The tagline to talk about the
scale of the problem we face
is the number 20 terawatts.
This is the number--
and it's useful to
spell it out in digits.
This is the number that measures
the rate at which humanity uses
primary energy, 20 times 10
to the 12th joules per second
of primary energy.
90% of this energy
comes from burning
carbon and its
associated compounds,
about a quarter of
it from petroleum,
it from coal, about
a quarter of it
from natural gas,
10% from biomass and
waste, and only about 6%
from renewable hydropower.
And hydropower has already
been developed to the extent
it can be developed.
That leaves about 2% left
for the modern renewables
of wind and solar energy.
I think 20 terawatts is a
hard number to comprehend.
So I want to try to translate
it into some pictures
and some images that will make
it more persuasive to you.
This is a coal train
winding its way
through the mountains
of the American west.
And 20 terawatts is the energy
equivalent to 2 million tons
of coal per hour fueling
our modern economy.
I could have shown some pictures
of the skyline of Singapore
or the docks of
Long Beach to try
to show you the scope of the
enterprise that this fuels.
But you have to appreciate
that this is an amazing scope.
Now, we don't burn 20
million tons of coal.
I've reduced the oil
and the natural gas
and the biomass to the
equivalent amount of coal
to just give you a picture of
the effort that's involved.
To make this more concrete,
a typical coal train
has about 120 cars.
It's got about 120
tons of coal per car.
That's 15,000 tons per train.
And we need about 130 fully
loaded trains of that nature
to supply the energy that our
civilization thrives on and is
using in greater
amount all the time.
I'm not going to let
go of this easily.
Let me try to say
it another way.
This is a large coal-fired
power plant in England.
It uses about 3 gigawatts
worth of power constantly
to produce about 1
gigawatt of electricity.
In order to find an equivalent
to the carbon dioxide
that we pump into
the atmosphere,
it would be equivalent to 3,200
of these large coal-fired power
plants operating continuously,
24 hours a day, all year long.
That's the rate at which
we're putting carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere.
I'd rather think
about renewables.
So let me try to convert this
number into something that
relates to renewable energy.
These are solar panels.
They're the highest
efficiency way
we have of gathering
solar energy in a very
high-quality form.
And to supply our
civilization with the energy
that we require,
it would require
a million square kilometers
of silicon photovoltaics
at their current
efficiency spread out
over the tropical deserts.
And the tropical deserts are
chosen just because they're
the sunniest
cloud-free areas where
you could place solar panels
and get the most sunshine.
The lesson I want
to take from this
is that transforming society
to sustainable energy
is heavy lifting.
This is a huge problem.
It's not going to be
solved unless we marshal
the resources of our culture
and convince leaders,
political leaders and
economists, that changes
in behavior and
changes in investment
have to be made over a very
short time span in order
to bring a sustainable
energy revolution.
The second thing I
want to talk about
is the second law
of thermodynamics.
And it's hard to talk to
non-technical audiences
about the second law
of thermodynamics.
So I want to try to say
it in non-technical form.
The simplest non-technical form
is that there is no free lunch.
Another way of saying it is
that disorder in the universe
can only increase with time.
But the implication
I want to talk
about today is that
some forms of energy
are more useful than others.
The most useful
forms of energy are
those that have what
we call zero entropy
or very negligible entropy,
negligible disorder.
And the two striking examples
are mechanical energy
and electromagnetic energy.
They can be translated
directly into useful work
for humanity's needs.
Thermal energy, heat,
is of varying quality
depending upon its temperature.
And sunlight is probably
the highest quality form
of heat energy that's
available to us.
It comes from the sun with a
temperature of 6,000 degrees
Kelvin, which is about
10,000 degrees Fahrenheit.
It's really hot.
And that means it's
very high quality.
In particular, the second
law of thermodynamics
limits the efficiency at
which you can convert sunlight
to the most usable form
of energy, electricity.
And that limit is 95%.
That's really wonderful.
It means that sunlight
is a tremendous resource.
It can be converted
directly into useful work
at a 95% level.
Well, we use solar panels
to collect light and turn it
directly into
usable electricity.
And there's been
research on solar panels
for generations now.
They're becoming cost
effective and competitive
with fossil fuels.
They're being mounted in large
solar farms across our country
and elsewhere in the world.
And their net
efficiency, the rate
at which they turn solar energy
into electricity, is 6% to 7%.
So we started with a
resource which is 95%
potential useful energy.
And what we can get
out of it with the best
of our efficient
solar panels on a per
square meter basis
is between 6% and 7%.
So let me contrast
that with warmth.
And the example I want to
use is ocean thermal energy.
Now, people have known
for years that the surface
of tropical oceans is warm
compared to the abyssal depths.
In fact, the surface of
tropical oceans averages
about 27 degrees
centigrade, and the depths
are just a few degrees above
freezing, 5 degrees centigrade.
There's a picture
here showing a slice
through some tropical
ocean where you can see
the very hot water on the top.
And the depth with the
purple and magenta color
indicates very cold water.
And you can build an engine.
Just like you can build an
engine that works on coal,
you can build an engine
that takes that heat
from the surface
waters, runs an engine,
and dumps the extra
entropy that must
be created, the extra
disorder, into the cold water
at the depths.
The same laws of
thermodynamics that
allow solar energy
to be at most,
theoretically, 95% efficient
allow ocean thermal energy
to be 7% efficient.
That's the best
you could do if you
satisfied all the conditions of
efficiency that are available.
So what's the situation?
Well, there are devices
that have been proposed.
And a couple have been
set up experimentally.
This is a kind of cross
section to such a device that
takes warm water at the
surface, runs an engine,
and dumps cold water at depth.
And nobody's achieved
anything that
can be measured as
an efficiency so far.
So if 95% ramps down
to 7% by the time
we're finished with our
crude ways of getting power,
where's 7% going to take us?
So I want to end on
an optimistic note.
This is my last slide.
I want to just emphasize
the promise of solar energy.
This is a resource
that streams to Earth
at about 20,000 times the
rate at which human beings use
energy.
It's high quality.
It can be harvested efficiently.
We don't know how
to do that yet.
We don't know how to
store it effectively.
And we don't know
how to transmit it
as effectively as we should.
But the resource is immense.
And the conversion to electrical
energy at high efficiency
is possible.
And at moderate efficiency
is really within grasp.
And it offers the promise for
a renewable energy future.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'd like to invite the
panel up for discussion.
So what we're going to do,
we have half an hour, right?
OK.
So what we're going to do is
we would love your questions,
your comments, your thoughts.
A room like this
is kind of funny
because we're here in the front.
You're back there.
It really should
be in the round.
We should be all sitting around
because we're in one room.
We should all have a
discussion, actually.
I'm going to start
it off, though,
as you're thinking about your
questions and your comments.
And when you do have a question,
please come up to the mics.
Tell us your name and
ask your question.
So I'm going to start off
with Tomás, appropriately.
So Bob's thoughts
about a transition
to a low-carbon world and
the numbers behind that
are illuminating.
And I always think of Bob as the
keeper of the laws of nature,
right?
I wish.
And I'd actually really
like to hear more, Tomás,
about the bridge to
a fossil-free future.
You use that tagline.
And actually, maybe Joaquin,
the work that you showed
was really compelling
because there's
a pathway that involves
citizen science and community
engagement, which is
something completely different
than necessarily the
technological and the science
pathway.
Could you talk a
little bit more?
And Joaquin, if you want to
say a few words, as well.
Yeah, I can-- it's working.
No, I'm interested
in models of--
Bob, you could maybe relay
this thermodynamic imagination
that we are trying to pursue
in this elemental way of--
because there is always this
coupling of metabolic regimes,
how we have been living
on planet Earth, and how,
in different times, humans
have evolved in relationship.
How were they grasping
the resources, no?
The first kind of
metabolic regime,
we were hunter and
gatherers, nomads,
tribes around the world.
We would always follow the
season, follow the sun, right?
Then we invented agriculture.
We became sedentary.
The second metabolic,
we domesticated the sun,
domesticated the animals.
And somehow, we managed
to become sedentary
in a certain area.
In the third
metabolic regime, we
learned how to extract
more from the sun.
And we learned how
to burn charcoal,
which somehow a rock--
how many millions
of years of sun
influence it needed to
then be able to burn?
This means we start to have
all these extractive economies,
which somehow also
expanded civilization
to become again this kind of--
I think how much population
are living on the cities.
The fourth metabolic regime
that somehow we are proposing
is like what happened
when these extractive
economies and all these
resources and also the way of--
because every metabolic
regime somehow also
has allowed different modes
of aggregation of people.
When we were nomads, the
tribes cannot grow to a certain
extent.
Then the other ones keep
growing, keep growing.
This means the
relationship we always
have established of
how we have related
our society with the sun
through these metabolic regimes,
they always give products
of transportation,
mobility, and so forth.
These are rather
speculation things.
Because what it does
is it crosses this idea
of very elemental, no?
The sun is heated up.
You don't need a solar
panel, a battery,
or convert it to
electricity directly.
You get to maybe something
I like to speculate.
After Homo sapiens, maybe
we became Homo floatantes.
And we became numb at the
beginning of the atmosphere.
And you might think, oh, we were
fishes floating in the water.
Why we moved to the land?
And what would be the
benefit to move into the air?
This means we live there.
But really try to
maybe get it around.
Anyone else want to say?
Well, maybe I just
would add one thing,
that I think that a
transformation of society's
way of thinking about
its culture and energy
is a really important
part of dealing
with the energy transfer,
the transformation
to renewable energy.
We demand that we can turn
on our washing machine
at any time of day.
We expect to be able to take
a car wherever we want to go.
And the variability
of energy sources
that you have to deal with,
for example, with solar energy
versus infrared energy,
if human beings adapted
to the cadences at which
energy is available,
it would make a
big impact on what
we have to do in order to
reach a sustainable future.
So please come up to the mics.
I actually want to
follow up with Joaquin.
I'm going to ask you to
say some words because I'm
very curious about
a particular thing.
So the outcomes that
you are after when
engaging the community,
especially a community that
is under pressure from
environmental conditions,
right?
What happens?
What are the actions
that the community takes?
All right.
To begin with, I'm
going to be honest.
Sometimes I feel a little
pessimistic about weather
and climate change.
I have a few friends in
Harvard who are architects
and are actually here.
And yesterday, we were
talking about what we called
the brace for impact scenario.
And I was asking them,
when is that coming?
And we realized
that we are already
living the brace
for impact scenario
because of the amount of
times we are seeing all
these extreme weather events.
And so in terms of
community, I think
this is going to
change us a lot.
We are going to have to
find new ways to relate
to each other, new ways to help
each other, new ways to learn
from each other.
And this is why I
envisage this future
of technological developments
that might seem basic
but might actually
be very helpful,
like this idea of creating
a solar aerial mesh network.
And I imagine places
where there have
been floods in the past years.
And how do you deploy
a relief efforts team
to a place that has
suffered a natural disaster?
And this is where I think
of this network that
runs on clean solar energy.
But just to sum
it up, I very much
agree with Bob of the
sheer size of the problem.
And actually, each of
us has a role in this.
And maybe we can start
thinking how to live
more energy-efficient life.
So thanks.
Thank you.
Questions?
No one's stepping up.
Yeah, Caroline?
So this may be a challenge
for my dear friend Tomás.
But I would be
interested in the others.
The human architectural
fascination with life
in a capsule.
So the sky city, the cloud
city, the Bucky Fuller spaceship
city, these are, in
fact, incredibly energy
intensive, right?
They are the sort of emotional
manifestation of freedom
that is the result of
energy-intensive manufacturing
processes, delivery systems,
infrastructures of power
that are somehow brought up
there as batteries or whatever.
So in a way, it's a challenge
to the nomadic fantasy
and how this is coupled with
the very elaborated technologies
that would make such
a cloud city possible.
It's a tough question.
It's like tough love.
No, I think so.
I think so.
It's so simple as you can
start to reuse a plastic bag.
Instead of downgrading
material, you
upscale the relationship
you have with plastic bags.
I'm very happy that now plastic
bags through [INAUDIBLE]
into community suddenly
can give another lifespan,
or the lifespan corresponds
with the ability of themself
to be within the
environment we have created.
Or the other metaphor
is the city in a ball.
OK, now let's put it away.
Oh, Juan Rodriguez is there.
Now, first, I don't know.
I would almost say it's like
the idea of, in [INAUDIBLE],,
we are condemned to
live in a sublunar.
The Bible is somehow
planet Earth today.
And we have a kind of
an environmental justice
responsibility, also, the
amount of people who are onboard
on this Spaceship Earth.
And Bruno doesn't
like an analogy.
But somehow, I think, so
when you understand also
the constraint of
where we are living,
you are living in a bubble
to a certain extent, right?
And there are some
resources that somehow maybe
you can start to
relate differently.
There is this kind
of logic on that.
The other is also like
when you think in the way
that I propose, I
think, it's like--
and I think what
the other thing does
is also how to fly with
the feet on the ground.
This means there is a
huge responsibility.
So when you scale it too
fast, too quickly, then you
end up in a modernist dream.
But the way of how we are
doing the things today here
with Joaquin, with Lodo,
with the measurement,
the quality of the
air, well, let's
give it a little bit more time.
Phil had also said there
is no lack of energy.
There is no energy crisis.
There is a crisis of
imagination and how
we can couple and recouple
ourself with the environment.
So the relationship
of trying to say
is like, oh, how complex is--
when I was at NASA in 2009,
people had put
people in the moon.
And I said, for 300
euro, you collect
a couple of plastic bags,
and you can lift up yourself
from the ground.
They cannot believe it.
There is somehow
such an addiction
of people of thinking
the infrastructure
you need to do such a thing--
that is unbelievable for
them to get out of this.
And any time that
you demonstrate,
these people say, oh,
there's some kind of magic.
Now, I challenge yourself.
And let's put it away.
And you know that
this is quite cheap.
We are really
working now seriously
on something which is a
300-meter sphere, diameter,
which can be able to lift up
a couple of hundred people up
into the air, rigid sphere.
And it's incredibly
cheap, if I tell you.
And the infrastructure
is something
that even an artist can
understand and reteach
to a whole community of
scientists or re-engage
onto understanding how we can
sense the sun differently.
I mean, just only--
I mean, with Lodo, we know.
But I've been with
director of NASA and people
at [INAUDIBLE] saying, what is
the average on a jet stream?
They don't know it.
How long it will take you
to make it around the world?
Actually, only what you know is
like, OK, in the current plane,
you got to your
destination half an hour
early if the wind was blowing.
But now if you are
drifting, if you
are in a kind of
drift situation,
it takes quite an effort.
And I think so it's not
right to all the time
condemn some idea for
thinking that infrastructure
is so gigantic.
Well, actually,
it's very simple.
It's simple as a plastic bag
in the hands of somebody else.
Great answer.
Yep.
Please.
So my question is regarding
the solar balloons
that you guys talked about.
So assuming that you
will be able to launch
these balloons at the
location that you like to,
what is the vision?
What is the plan if you
collect all this data
all across the planet?
Then where does that
data go, and what are you
expecting to get out of it?
What is the plan for?
The panel could speak
to it a little bit.
The second question is for the
efficiency of the solar power.
So I want to find out
what is the bottleneck
not to have higher efficiency.
And so what is the
efficiency that we
are aiming for to replace that
130 coal trains per hours?
So can you give us a sense
what we are looking at there?
I can start with the
collection of the data.
As I mentioned before, there
are different types of data
you can collect.
If you go higher up in the
stratosphere, normally,
you would be
monitoring the ozone.
The ozone layer is very
important for life on Earth.
And if you have a
depletion of ozone,
you can get the [INAUDIBLE]
light which comes to Earth,
and it would be very damaging.
So this is why the monitoring
to make sure that we-- we
had an example of an
ozone hole not long ago.
We're just recovering
out of that.
So it's the kind of
monitoring to make sure.
But there are other gases, like
Dan has been mentioning about,
like CO2, methane, which are
very important as a greenhouse.
So the increase of those
gases makes the temperature
on Earth increase enormously.
And so we want to
monitor to make sure
that those are not
increasing too much
and what is the
trend that we notice.
So those are the upper level.
Low level with a
tethered balloon,
you can actually
monitor the air quality.
So all this particles
I was talking about
and chemicals are very
damaging to your health.
So they're the result
mainly of combustion.
They can produce acid
rain And there are also
particles at cell
phone dimensions
that can be very, very
bad for your health.
So the quality of
the air locally
is very important
for where you live.
And if it's monitored,
in the summertime,
you have a lot of sometimes
pollutant trapped in the lower
troposphere.
And it can be very--
I come from a region
of Milan where
you have very poor air quality.
We have heard about Beijing
and all these big cities.
So they can be very
efficient in measuring
what is the chemistry of those
lower tropospheric layers,
what's going on there, and how
we can control the pollution.
So there are different types
of monitoring we can do.
To follow up on
what Lodo just said,
another thing that we've really
struggled with as scientists
over the last couple of
decades is shrinking budgets.
And there's really only a
handful of research aircraft
that we can do these
high-quality measurements with,
especially talking about
things like the ozone layer.
We're still relying on Cold
War-era aircraft, ER-2s,
the old U-2 spy planes
that have been retasked,
things like that.
They cost many tens of
thousands of dollars per hour.
They're absolutely necessary
to validate new satellites that
go up to understand the quality
of the ozone to make sure
that the ozone hole is, indeed,
still closing, something
that we are just getting out of.
And so the idea that we might
have these platforms that
could allow us to do this at
much lower cost in many more
locations is really
intriguing and the surface
measurements, as well.
We're notoriously bad about
making most of our measurements
in the northern hemisphere,
where most of the developed
countries are, and
notoriously bad about making
too few measurements in
the southern hemisphere.
And this idea of
low-cost platforms
that we could look at
these types of problems,
understand air
quality, for example,
in some of the large cities
in the southern hemisphere
is something that we critically
need to do as scientists.
Could I add that, for
example, Joaquin's example,
he's talking about communities
outside Buenos Aires, which
are very badly
affected by pollution.
You can see them.
We had an example
like that in Venice.
Venice is a beautiful city.
When I was growing up,
you will approach Venice,
and you will have a huge
chemical plant there.
And there was terrible quality.
So they probably are
in the same situation.
But you can improve
that with rules.
And your health is badly
affected by the pollution.
So the idea is just to
prove that to the government
so that they can do
something about it.
No, you do it by yourself.
There are people
collecting data.
We collect it.
We will do the
experiment on Saturday.
We can collect data.
You can have communities.
Joaquin is trying
to make a community
responsible for trying to
collect some more information.
And then the data itself, if
you can show that it is so bad,
you can force some
political action.
Yeah.
There is a group we work
which is called-- well,
beside being [INAUDIBLE],,
part of Red Cross,
also, which they
kind of engage also.
Within the project,
there is a group
which is called Public Lab.
They do a lot of
environmental justice.
And it's been in
the hands of them.
They provide a lot of
downgrading or kind
of low-scale monitoring
devices, which
we hope so will work together
with high scientists,
with low communities, also,
coming up together with.
And they are building
huge cases, also,
to big multinational,
also, in the case of Shell,
which is coming up
in the [INAUDIBLE],,
what Joaquin is talking.
You can build up huge cases on
trying to measure and give it
in the hands of them
the way you have
to monitor the environment.
I think I owe you an
answer to the second part
of your question.
Please.
Really, there are
two things to say.
The first is that 7% as a final
efficiency for solar energy
is not as bad as it may sound.
It's more that
it's a bad starting
place for ocean thermal energy.
I was writing an
article about this,
and I said a million square
kilometers is half the surface
area of Libya.
And the person I
was writing it for
said, people don't
know how big Libya is,
so maybe you should convert
it to Texas plus Oklahoma.
So then it becomes a problem
of storage and transmission.
People are very refractory
about having transmission lines
strung across their landscape.
But high-voltage DC electric
transmission is very efficient
and could carry electricity
from far-away places
to where it's needed.
The second is, how did
95% get down to 7%?
Some people in the
audience may be
perplexed because you can
read that the efficiency of PV
modules now is about 20%.
But when you lay them
out on the landscape,
they have to be
tilted at an angle.
And they block each other.
There have to be
pathways between them
so that people can
walk and clean them
up when they get dirty.
There's piping and
support structures.
There are inverters that
change it from DC to AC.
And that knocks it down
by a factor of about 2
and 1/2 from 20% to 7 and 1/2%.
In principle, silicon
can get to about 30%
efficiency consistent with
the laws of thermodynamics.
Great.
Mary?
Responding to the visionary
nature of the project
and some of the earlier
works, such as city skies,
I'm curious if the panel could
comment on whether or not
they think that it's
possible to even imagine
physically a floating city.
I've been very inspired by
and interested in Buckminster
Fuller's Cloud Nine
project, which is maybe
a related project, a city
with a mile-wide diameter
that floats in the sky.
He makes a very persuasive
argument to a layperson.
But I'm curious to know if the
panel has any thoughts about
whether or not this
could be possible.
Yeah.
I think so.
I mean, the problem
is sometimes you--
something which
is very beautiful,
if you really take
the challenge yourself
and you really try to
build it and to build it
with infrastructure which
is different than the
infrastructure that
usually things are built
and with such a responsibly
distributed agency of how
the project grows bit by bit--
sometimes I'm very anxious.
It would be very different
color, very different
understanding of what it
might be, these cloud cities,
and which type of
political challenge
we might be facing with them.
Now, something very simple.
When we float and we make a
world-wide record to lift up
a person in the air with a
certified vehicle in the White
Sands, when we were
trying to repeat
the same in a surface
which is not white,
we were not lifting
even one person.
This means your power
of how much people
you can carry up into the
air is really dependent
about a surface, the albedo,
the reflectivity of the Earth.
And this means this
could be the clouds,
or it could be the
surface of the air.
You can also see and think
about a sea when it's very calm
and you don't have so
much ripple in the water.
This means this balloon is
kind of an amazing thermometer.
It's an amazing sensor,
will go up and down
and really weave something which
are-- because humans still,
we are so similar.
Oh, you cannot
look at the cosmos.
You're not looking at the--
you're out of the scale,
is the problems of all on Earth.
But there are few people
who really understand
this choreography, this
relationship between the Earth
and the sun, this idea
what Lodo was doing,
this drawing, going
up and going down
and being able to understand
these boundary layers where
we live.
And people sometimes are very--
oh, [INAUDIBLE],, you got that,
or you are getting here.
You cannot be in between.
And it's like every
time you try to--
and this means this
tomorrow is like-- we became
so much weather dependent.
Isn't this tomorrow
or maybe not?
Tomorrow, maybe not.
And day after tomorrow, not.
And remember, all the
psychology of people
is like a turnkey solution.
It's a cut down.
Well, here, the cut down
is much more gentle.
You see the sun coming
from the horizon.
You kind of float.
Gravity seems to reverse itself.
Space is top to be at.
The current line is
300 kilometers high
where objects start to fall.
When we fall upward,
we reverse our senses.
Stay with the motion.
You move with the wind.
You became the wind.
There are a lot of--
I mean, if you take
it serious, start to,
I think so-- in the moment that
a cloud city might be up there,
I think we might
have solved already
down here on planet Earth.
I mean, we have
been learning how
to live on that bubble
called Earth today.
And maybe we might get
ready to get another step
towards somewhere
else, the solar sails
and wherever it might be there.
I don't know.
Another thing, for
example, [INAUDIBLE]
Institute, kind of the
MIT from Germany, says,
one might be kind of a
monument that we have built
Eiffel Tower, the London Eye.
Think about a city again
because usually, what we do
is educational.
When it's a high
wind voltage, you
have a lot of problem
to storage in batteries
and the distribution, also.
And this means the
best things you
can do when you
have a lot of wind,
you get an SMS in your
telephone telling you,
now wash your
clothes because it's
cheaper at the high
rate of-- that's
the moment you have
to consume energy
because there is a lot of wind.
And this means we're
thinking like, OK,
think about a mini cloud city.
Something when it's very windy,
usually, it will be down.
This means it's the time
to wash your clothes.
This means the Eiffel Tower
could fly up and down.
And it's a symbol for the
city of reconnecting yourself
with something
that sometimes you
can just pick up the clothes
and put it under the sun to dry.
It's very tortuous,
this addiction
we have to certain relation.
So I actually want to dive
into this question myself.
So I run a group called
the Urban Metabolism Group.
And what we do is
account for the resources
that we all consume
on an annual basis.
So are floating cloud
cities possible?
Well, so all of you on average
in this part of the world
consume between 25 and 30
tons per capita per year.
So if we can figure out a way
to put 20 to 30 tons per capita,
each one of us up in the
sky, then it's possible, yes.
The other answer I want to
give, the other the second part
to this answer is there is
a city of 8 million people
in the sky every day, in fact.
That's the average number
of people who fly every day.
And they're connected on
their iPads and everything.
So there is a city
in the sky today.
It's fossil fuel driven.
It's not that vision.
But it's absolutely there.
So that's really very
much our reality.
Other questions?
Please go to the mic if you can.
The question is more
about [INAUDIBLE]
you say about having that
city floating, by example.
80 years ago, just
thinking about flying,
just one person flying
by itself, right?
Now you can have 380 floating.
And he's right.
It's almost a city floating
there, just with an engine.
But when you really make
your imagination go,
it's feasible that
you start floating
there or the helium balloons.
So that's quite feasible.
Now, my question here is
there's great minds here trying
to do the right thing.
But then you have the other
side, the economy side.
And they say, you know what?
We are the owners of
the oil companies.
We really don't want to fund
you because if we fund you,
we're going to be useless.
How we deal with that politics
side and say, you know what?
How do we convince
the people that
has the funding to actually
invest in the right thing
to do?
I don't want to
fund you because I
want to keep sustaining myself.
I don't care about
what's happening
with the rest of that.
Who would like to tackle that?
Come on Friday.
Come tomorrow and
day after tomorrow.
We keep talking.
You know what I mean?
We might get it.
It's interesting, these panels.
It strikes me that this
could be a day-long symposium
because there are some major
themes that are just going
to get not really touched on.
But this is obviously
one of them.
I guess I could just
say a word on it,
maybe taking it one step
further, which is that it's
very hard for us to say.
We live here in a developed
country that developed itself
on a carbon economy, right?
I mean, so we have
the quality of life
that we have because
of fossil fuels here.
Everything around us
was built on that.
And so one of the problems
is, moving forward,
not just keeping things the same
but acknowledging that there's
developing countries.
And this is like saying
to them, you can't develop
in the same way
that we did, but not
at the same time offering
them a replacement technology.
So I guess I'm just taking
your question maybe one
step further.
But I firmly believe that
one of the things that we
are going to have
to do as a society
is make the hard
choices coming up.
And I think it was pointed out
that we've already maybe gotten
to this point where we see the
onset of severe storms, higher
temperatures, heat
deaths, things like that.
At some point, we're
not going to be
able to ignore it anymore.
And because a few
corporations wish
to continue to
make a profit, it's
not going to balance out
with the increasing penalties
that we're all paying
as a civilization,
as a society for those things.
And it's going to
be a slow process.
I don't think that-- some
people think about turning
fossil fuels off tomorrow.
That's not going to happen.
It's going to be
a gradual decline.
Some of those power
plants you were showing
were being put online now, and
they have lifetimes of decades.
Those aren't going
to be shut off.
The ones that are
coming online today
are going to be around as long
as I'm going to be around.
But what we can
hope is that there's
going to be more of
the renewables, maybe
some of the other alternative
energy technologies coming
into play, and that we slowly
ramp those things down.
But I do have to bring
us back to this idea
that we do have to think
about developing countries
at the same time, handing
technology off to them
and trying to see them
develop not in our footsteps,
not with the carbon
footprint that we've
had, but with a new
footprint, hopefully much more
renewable, hopefully much more
of these alternative energies.
So sorry if I interrupted.
We have to be--
No, not at all.
Well, I wanted to say
a couple of things.
One is that I think
it's a delusion
to think that the
laws of physics
are going to be surmounted
in the next era.
100 years ago, people
didn't know how to fly.
And now they know how to fly.
That's true.
But the laws of buoyancy
have been understood
for a long time, as have
the laws of absorption
and the emission of radiation.
And there's no sign
that there's going
to be a change in those
laws over the lifetime
that we're concerned with.
The other thing I wanted to
mention is I really want to say
a word in favor of the kind of
art that Tomás is involved in.
I think art has a
political impact
and can be used to
agitate and change
people's minds about things.
And when you talk about
influencing companies,
if you create a movement, if
you create political agitation,
if you elect people
who will pass a carbon
tax to place a cost on the
externalities of filling up
the atmosphere
with a toxic gas, I
think you'll have
the possibility
of making real changes.
Yup.
The other, which I want to add,
we have to be very careful.
And maybe Caroline
can help me and Leila
on the idea of the we, we, we.
No, there are many people that
hate the term "Anthropocene"
because actually, who produces
these mess where we are living
is a small percentage
of a population who
live on planet Earth.
And then many people call
it a Capitalocene, right?
This means we have
to be very careful.
Because all of a sudden,
it's like, we, we, we.
Well, actually,
there are many people
who know how to live and
relate on planet Earth actually
causing the problem that then
later are putting in danger
the people who are
suffering the consequences
of hyperconsumptions.
It's really imbalanced.
And then somehow we always
keep calling "we humans," where
we put everybody in the bag.
It's quite a complicated
issue over that.
So we're at the end
of the panel session.
Thank you so much for coming.
But please join me in
thanking the panel.
[APPLAUSE]
And especially Tomás and
Joaquin and the whole team.
Please join us in Lobby 10
for the Aerocene demonstration
of the flow predictor.
And weather permitting,
tomorrow and Saturday,
please join us in Killian Court
for floating the Aerocene.
Thank you.